over the last few years organic food has
spread like wildfire
despite higher prices buying organic is
turning from an
alternative into a moral and social
responsibility
organic food is supposedly healthier
more natural
and more ethical but what do we even
mean when we say
organic there's no global consensus
so different regions have different
definitions and rules
in general organic food is farmed
without gmo seeds
synthetic fertilizers or synthetic
pesticides
instead organic farmers use more
traditional ways of producing food like
crop rotation
and use organic fertilizers such as
compost or manure
while the motivation to buy organic food
is clearly noble
is it actually effective or just another
costly trend we can skip
without feeling guilty
[Music]
is organic food healthier one idea
associated with organic crops
is that their natural cultivation is
supposed to make them more nutritious
and healthier indeed several studies
found that organic foods contain
more antioxidants plants produce them as
a sort of homemade pesticide
organic plants seem to have to work a
little harder while regular plants have
plenty of help from humans
antioxidants are believed to have some
health benefits
although scientists are still on the
fence about them in general
we have no idea if and how exactly they
help us
or how much produce you'd have to eat to
absorb a certain amount
what about organic being more nutritious
well the evidence is mixed some studies
found that organic food can have
slightly higher concentrations of
vitamin c
and omega-3 fatty acids while others did
not find significant differences
overall the mixed evidence suggests that
there are only
small differences in nutritional value
so from the science available so far it
doesn't look like organic food has
significant health benefits
what we do know is that eating fruit and
veggies in general is good for you
and most of us don't do that enough
eating veggies
is more important for your health than
how they were produced
is organic food more natural
people don't only buy organic to get
extra vitamins
but to avoid something toxic artificial
pesticides and fertilizers
and indeed several studies show that
there actually is
less pesticide residue on organic
produce
but here's where things get complicated
less pesticide does not mean none at all
while pesticides are supposed to be a
last resort in organic farming
they're not forbidden most organic
pesticides are natural toxins like
vegetable oils
hot ash soap sulfur or copper sulfates
but there are synthetic substances as
well
what's the difference between organic
and regular pesticides
not a lot actually organic pesticides
are not necessarily safer than
conventional ones
toxic is toxic no matter if the
substance is manufactured
or derived from nature in fact in the
case of copper sulfate
often used on organic apples the organic
pesticide of choice is actually more
harmful to humans
the toxicity of any substance depends on
its concentration
and your exposure to it not if it's
natural or not
there are few recent studies about how
our current level of pesticide exposure
affects our long-term health a 2018
study from france associated never
eating organic food with a higher risk
of certain cancers
the study was criticized a lot though
the participants reported their dietary
habits themselves
while no actual tests of pesticide
levels in their bodies were done
complicating things even more a danish
study from 2018 found that the danger
from pesticides for an adult
was similar to drinking a glass of wine
every three months
the pesticides on your vegetables are
nothing to lose sleepover
despite this we should continue to
demand strict standards for our food
all pesticides are regulated and tested
very strictly
in the eu and the us every year
thousands of food samples are screened
for pesticides
the majority of samples have no residues
or just a fraction of the tolerance
level
right now contamination from bacteria
and fungi is much more dangerous
and on this front the risk is the same
be it organic or regular food
is organic food better for the
environment
[Music]
2017 a meta-analysis looked at organic
farming in detail
and analyzed organic and regular foods
from over 700 production sources
and their impact on categories like
greenhouse gas emissions
energy consumption and land needs
the result no production method is
clearly better for the environment
organic systems use less energy than
conventional ones
but have similar greenhouse gas
emissions
organic farms use less pesticide but
need much more land to produce the same
amount of crop
these mixed results were also confirmed
by a report from the swedish food agency
organic and regular were equal in most
regards
the biggest difference was land use and
here conventional farming clearly won
and ecotoxicity where organic farming
has a clear advantage
so according to these results
conventional farming
actually has a little bit less impact on
the environment compared to organic
the bottom line is organic food isn't
superior to regular produce
as far as we know but organic
agriculture also has an
impact at a broader level demand is
rising constantly
and the struggle to supply the market
can lead to production methods that are
less sustainable in other ways
spain for example grows tons of regular
and organic vegetables destined for
export
in vast greenhouse areas which use a lot
of energy
and have other environmental impacts
such as significantly higher greenhouse
gas emissions
and because growing demand can't be
covered by domestic production
the global trade in organic foods is
also increasing
as supply chains get more and more
complex to make all kinds of foods
available in organic quality
ensuring organic quality standards and
regulations gets
ever more difficult this has led to
incidences of fraud
where conventional food was labeled and
sold as expensive organic produce
but organic versus conventional food
isn't even an objective discussion
organic is not simply a production
method for many it's an ideology
buying organic feels right people want
to do the correct thing for the health
of their children
and the well-being of the planet but our
instinct to think of organic
as good and conventional as bad
can get in the way of making the most
reasonable decision
the solution could be to stop seeing
organic and conventional farming as
irreconcilable they both have pros and
cons
and the best way to produce healthy food
efficiently would be a combination of
their best features
and as for your personal shopping what
food you should buy
depends on what you expect from it if
you simply want to eat healthily
you should buy more fruit and veggies of
any kind not necessarily organic
if your concern is for the environment
then simply buying organic won't solve
this problem for you
the easiest option is to buy local food
that's in season
basically seasonal is the true organic
to sum up an organic label is a
manufacturing notice
not a security certificate or a silver
bullet for your diet
what you eat is much more important than
how it's produced
production is very important for our
animations though we make them with a
lot of love and care
and the best thing is you can learn how
to do them
court because i've joined skillshare our
favorite online learning community for
creators
with a three-part series of 2d animation
classes
skillshare offers more than 25 000
classes on everything from film
writing design and technology from
skilled experts
the premium membership gives you
unlimited access for only ten dollars a
month
but we got you a treat the first 1000
people to use the link in the
description
get their first two months for free so
to kick off 2019
if you want to give animation a try and
breathe life into our characters
or learn something else to fuel your
creativity or even career
now you can
[Music]